اختفى العشرات من الاطفال الطالب اللجوء
في بريطانيا بظروف غامضه وسط انباء عن
اختطافهم من قبل عصابات اجراميه وفق لي
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه التي اوضحت
كذلك بان اختطاف الاطفال اللاجئين تم من
فندق تديره وزاره الداخليه رغم التحذير
المتكرري لها كما افاد المبلغون عن حالات
الاختطاف ان العمليه كانت على الشارع
الرئيسي وباستخدام سيارات مختلفه
ومن امام ذات الفندق الذي اختفى منه
الاطفال في مدينه برايتون ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض يعني قصه ملفته طلعتنا بها
صحيفه الجارديان عن اختفاء الاطفال طالبه
اللجوء في بريطانيا ربما ايضا في هذا
الفندق الذي همم يظهر خلفك في الصوره ما
زال لديك من تفاصيل حول هذا الموضوع حتى
الان
ابدا اولا نايف بان يشاهدت ااا يعني على
الاقل طفلين يعني ربما في حدود سن السادسه
عشر من العمر يعني خرجوا من هذا الفندق
وتوجهه الى الشاطئ على بعد تقريبا 100 100
متر ولا ربما ان القلق الذي يصور السلطات
المحليه وخاصه المجلس البلديه
حول الاخبار
او التحقيق الصحفي عن اختفاء العشرات من
هؤلاء الذين كانوا يقيمون في هذا الفندق
خلفي حسب
ما جاء في في هذا التحقيق ان همم مئه وسته
36 شخصا همم كانوا يقيمون في هذا الفندق
على مدى همم 18 شهرا همم اختفوا لاسباب لا
نعرفها بحسب يعني موظف
شركه لحمايه الاطفال تعاقدت مع وزاره
الداخليه بان بعضهم يعني تم اختطافهم ان
تاتي سيارات وهمم
ويتم نقلهم الى اماكن ربما بعيده عن مدينه
في جنوب شرقي انجلترا وبالتالي هذا همم
يعني اخبار يعني مثيره للغايه اذا اصطدمت
عامه الناس صدمت السياسيين واولئك الذين
يتابعون حقوق الطفل في المملكه المتحده
وبالتالي يعني
هذا الفندق
الذي يظهر خلفك في الصوره في مدينه هو
فندق تديره وزاره الداخليه فبالتالي هي
مسؤوله عن حمايه الاطفال داخل همم الفندق
او حتى هي من امنت شركه شركه لحمايت هؤلاء
الاطفال بالتالي لا يوجد هناك اي مبرر اي
سبب لديهم مقنع لسبب هذا الاختفاء او على
الاقل بحث عن هؤلاء
عاده النيف يعني كل يعني هذه الفنادق التي
يتم حجزها من قبل وزاره الداخليه هي اا
يعني لامتلاك شركات واشخاص ومستثمرين ما
تفعله وزاره الداخليه هو انها ت- تحجز كل
الغرف في الفندق هناك مثلا بالنسبه لهذا
الفندق هناك ما يقارب من 60 غرفه في همم
يعني همم يعيش فيها هؤلاء همم
بالنسبه همم يعني الاداره ربما هناك همم
مندوبون تابعون لوزاره الداخليه وايضا
هيئات تتعلق بحمايه الطفل يكونون في في
هذا الفندق يجب تذكير بان عاده همم في
الفنادق التي يتم استخدامها للاجئين يجب
على كل شخص يطرق الفندق ان اا يسجل نفسه
انه ترك واي بالضغط في اي ساعه وعند
العوده يجب ايضا ان يسجل اسمه مره ثانيه
توقيع بانه عاده الى الفندق هنا
انه هذه الفئات العمريه الصغيره التي يجب
حمايتها عندما تاتي الى المملكه المتحده
عبر طرق غير شرعيه وخاصه عبر القوارب سواء
يعني في همم في همم في مدينه دوفر او حتى
في مدن ساحليه اخرى يجب ان يحظوا برعايه
اجتماعيه عاده يجب ان لا تتعدى اقامته في
هذه الفنادق لاولائك همم الذين قتلوا
اعمارهم عن 18 عاما يجب نقله مباشره في
اقل من اسبوعين او سته عشر يوم تقريبا الى
هذه المراكز الاجتماعيه الخاصه بهم ولكن
بان في كثير من الحالات لم يتم الوفاء
بهذا التعاهد وان كانت الحكومه تعرف بانها
يجب ان تقدم كل ما يلزم لحمايه الطفل
اشكرك جزيلا شكرا على كل هذه المعلومات
من الفندق الذي اختفى منه الاطفال في
مدينه برايتون راس العربيه مصطفى زاهر
وشكرا لك